hey everyone
oh hello Oscar how was your vacation
that's very funny yeah I thought of that
like two seconds after you left
hi Angela
would you like to join the party
planning committee the committee with
all the women yeah because I'm gay no no
certain events have transpired
thought about certain things
and I'm sorry for the way those certain
events transpired
and I would just like to make make some
changes about certain things and certain
situations all right all right I'll join
I'd love to that's
thank you
can I join too
never
hey you guys excited about the party
it's gonna be fun yeah oh and look at
you
showing your colors I bet you we should
wear a dress every day what are you
implying oh good happy Halloween what
happened to all of those spooky
decorations that we had the cobwebs and
such yeah I don't know we put them all
up last night
well you know what go buy some more I'll
approve the overages
sound good yeah yeah good
oh yeah also about budget stuff
um I'm gonna need you to find like a a
full employee salary plus benefits like
50 Grand
I'm gonna need you to find 50 Grand the
numbers
but we don't keep two sets well that's
not what I'm saying just you know find
it pretend that your jobs depend on it
well I looked through all the budgets
and there is one Department yes that has
three people yeah doing the work that
could be done by two this is great
oh
yeah
well I need to give my cat up for
adoption
the one who uses the doorbell or the one
with the Mexican hat or the one with the
rain galoshes or the one that you let go
around naked Angela's cats are cute so
cute that you just want to eat them
but you can't eat cats
you can't eat cats Kevin
no the one with the long hair and the
denim pants Comstock
okay look he's such a special Kitty I
just want to find him a good home
he loves those pants
I'll take him
please after the turtle I am enormously
proud of what I did for that turtle
Oscar Oscar you take him no I'm a dog
person
if you pray enough you can
you give into a cat person
those guys always turn back Angela
excellent
so why would we
know what I think it is
good God oh
that one ugly cat is humping princess
lady
[Music]
this is where he is fixed I know fixed
that ain't fixed no way no now listen
you can't let what you see here selling
your image of them they are good decent
cats
like in an hour
oh the other one's watching
me when I talk to you do you hear me
[Music]
it's just getting weird
is she cleaning the cat with her tongue
oh
has this been on the entire time I have
no idea I was looking at pictures of
booed on my computer
well sorry I'm late
I want to get that image out of my head
the psychological issues that go behind
licking a cat are not things I want to
go into
also I'm pretty sure she caused a bear
ball thanks so much thank you so much
well
have we all calmed down yet yes sorry
about that
it was all my fault let's all try to do
better next time
Kevin great to see you yeah thank you
for the food oh and also you suck
I beg your pardon you are like a
terrible person these guys care about
you and you're just using them
again the food was very good
hey guys the Christmas party is today
Merry Christmas everyone no is it I mean
it says Xmas party but I think we all
know what that's code for so we're not
gonna have a Christmas party this year
Angela how could you do this to us oh
right like I'm responsible because I'm
in charge of the party planning
committee well you are the one in charge
don't blame me for me for something we
all forgot yeah let's not blame her for
something we all forgot
I didn't realize how many of Angela's
opinions I agreed with
until she tried to have my kneecap
shattered for sleeping with her husband
she makes a lot of very sound points
I knew the party was today but nobody
asked me to plan it so I didn't funny
how that works we're out there sweating
our balls off every day busting our
balls we deserve a Christmas party well
then why don't we just get some liquor
and those mini cupcakes mini cupcakes
as in the Mini version of regular
cupcakes which is already a mini version
of cake honestly where does it end with
you people
happy is it black because that would be
hilarious why
you know
would it be more hilarious than Angela
having a Chinese baby a little bit yeah
right guys back me up
a little bit oh did I win the pool uh no
right month wrong year well no one won
the pool Angela wasn't due for another
month we should all go to the hospital
visit her oh I'd love to but um oh man I
would but I can't miss any more work
well Kevin and I have to go because uh
accounting is its own little family yeah
Oscar's the dad I'm Oscar's dad and
Angela's my mom
why didn't you pack the Apple snacks why
didn't you pack the Apple snacks guys
because whenever I pack the bag you say
I do it wrong guys why don't you pack it
guys Kevin what do you want to see a
video of a weatherman who says bold
front instead of cold front it's insane
can't you see we're busy
he just needs his Apple
seriously Kevin
okay you go to the store Phillip Phillip
Phillip it's all about Philip I hate
Philip
yeah
Kevin Kevin oh you know my name well
that is shocking
Kevin could you not do that what I'm
moving the ink down in my pen for work
here use my pen don't tell me what to do
I don't need this and you obviously
don't need me Kevin where are you going
away tell Phillip that his stupid little
baby wish came true
hey Kev how you doing buddy can't hear
you
I'm giving you the silence treatment
has a feel being ignored
okay I guess it's just that uh Philip
got you something
yeah a 25 gift card iTunes I think
there's like seven dollars left
it's just his way of saying thanks for
letting me hang out in accounting so got
this from me sure
it's a really cool see you there bye
Phillips listen I high five
yay